do you think a lot of the reason that
marriages don't work is because people
don't have enough friendships as well
and they're looking for their partner
looking to their partner for
everything and it's just not possible
you teed that one up for me nicely thank
you
um i think there's a number of reasons
relationships don't work um
i'm not sure they're meant to work i'm
not sure they're part of our human
evolutionary dna to have pair bonded
lifelong intimate relationships with the
office oh that's interesting i i mean
our ancestors did not do that for a
million and a half years we've been
trying to do it for less than 10 000
years and it's never really worked real
well but that's why that's why we have
religion and a lot of rule systems to
say you have to do it uh and and if you
don't you're a failure uh kind of you
know shaming people into trying to make
it work so i i don't believe that they
that they actually are meant to work in
the way we think that they are i mean
even the whole idea of romantic love i i
heard some time that you know that's
only been around about 200 years that
we're going to get with somebody because
we have them and i heard that that
shakespeare wrote romeo and juliet to
show the extreme fallacy of romantic
love oh we love each other so much let's
kill ourselves you know it's it's it's
silly but
i do believe that relationships can be
powerful personal growth machines i say
that all the time if we approach them
consciously and realistically you know
if i get with my partner and think oh
because i think you're beautiful and
because i think your body's hot
therefore you're going to be an amazing
partner to me we're in trouble right or
if you get with a guy because you think
oh man he's he's six foot two and he's
got a nice build and you know he makes a
lot of money he'll make a great partner
now the things we base our decisions on
for getting with people often you know i
i tell i tell men all the time i mainly
work with men now i say you know
everything your male brain thinks that a
woman can do for you is wrong and i tell
women the same thing everything your
female brain thinks a man can do for you
is wrong
but
if two conscious people are willing to
accept the challenges the difficulty of
trying to create an intimate pair bonded
relationship with a member of the
opposite sex with all of our baggage
from childhood with all of our
relationship fears with all of our
defense mechanisms with all of our
production projections with all of
society's unrealistic expectations of
how they should work this as i said can
be a really powerful personal growth
machine so there's a lot of things that
cause relationships not to to to go long
term one is that they're they're
probably just not meant to um number two
is that the the the unrealistic
expectations we have of them is another
one how we be how we form these
relationships at least for me i'm a
terrible picker when it comes to
relationship i've bumbled my way through
every relationship i've got um i think
it was pia melody who wrote a lot about
codependency i read this years ago
said that we tend to be attracted to and
marry a person who has some of the worst
traits of both of our parents
oh my god so yeah let that sink in that
means unconsciously we get attracted to
people that that are giving us the
opportunity to work out our dad issues
and work out our mom issues and that
person picked us because we're giving
them the opportunity to work out their
dad issues and their moms horrible and
then we expect that's going to work for
a lifetime and we're going to be happy
the entire lifetime okay but if we know
that if we can be conscious of those
pieces we can actually watch that stuff
coming up and and work with it
especially if we have help if we have
you know coach therapist good resources
so back to your question and it goes
back to the whole differentiation thing
i think this idea of this pair bonded
lifelong intimate relationship with a
member of the opposite sex
like i said it's only existed we've only
tried to do it for a few thousand years
and what does happen is that a lot of
people who are not filling their own
buckets up with a lot of cooperative
reciprocal relationships come into
relationship feeling needy we find
somebody we're attracted to is basically
come fill my bucket meet my needs now
what makes this even what makes this
worse is that when most couples get
together
they start giving up whatever they had
going on in their life that made them
who they were when they met
you know maybe they start demanding that
of each other well you need to quit
hanging around with your guy friends you
need to hang around with your your
girlfriends or you know you need to
spend more time with me or you need to
not go out as much at night i i years
ago i knew somebody is actually um a
friend of a friend but when this couple
met the guy played on three softball
teams so he was playing softball all the
time they met dated he continued to play
softball they got married they got
married and his wife said now that we're
married you have to quit playing on so
many softball teams
and and i'm thinking that's not a fair
request you know they met when they you
know and she never said ahead of time if
we get married i expect you to play on
future softball teams but here's the
deal it's just an example of of we we do
this in spoken or unspoken ways it's
kind of like you're my girlfriend
therefore you should you're my boyfriend
therefore you should you're my wife
therefore you should therefore that's
why i call them ownership relationships
this is the definition of a fused
relationship i don't have all these
other things out here filling my bucket
up so therefore you should and you
better because i've given up all these
things to be in a relationship with you
that i did have when we met i'm even
emptier now than i was so i expect even
more you should fill me up and they're
not the same person that they were when
you met you're not the same person so
we've increased the odds of this not
working well by giving up the things we
did have in our life so to answer your
question when when i was doing marriage
therapy
almost religiously in the first session
with the couple i would tell them
usually before the end of the session
the best thing both of you can do for
your marriage is develop good same-sex
relationships the guy needs to have good
guy friends the woman needs to have good
girlfriends now what i found working
with a lot of nice guys a lot a lot of
men at work but don't have many good guy
friends and i tell men having good guy
friends is the foundation that you're
going to build a healthy relationship on
with a woman and so what happens is they
meet a woman and they make her their
best friend and they you know want her
to be everything for them and many women
do the same thing as well so yes i agree
that the best thing we can do with our
marriage in the beginning is
if we don't have them already develop
good relationships now i i take this
seriously i mentioned i've been in a
men's program for three years i've been
married to to my present wife a little
over four and a half years she's mexican
we live in mexico
she doesn't speak english i've had to
learn spanish in my 50s and 60s my step
kids don't speak english even though
they're supposed to be learning and um
so here i am
kind of isolated you know because my
spanish has gotten better but i'm not
i'm not fluent mexican style fluent i i
can't swear as good as the average
mexican
even though my wife does their best to
teach me um and yeah i didn't have many
guy friends down here um you know i'm
now raising kids again i work at home
uh my gym is in my house you know so
yeah i i just didn't have many male
connections and i knew
i knew the well-being of my marriage was
dependent on me having good guy friends
and so i was actually you know worked
leading a workshop talking about this
cooperative reciprocal relationship idea
and had some handouts that i was working
with the guys and i told them one of the
things i need to add to my list
that i need to add to my list of
cooperative reciprocal relationships is
a men's program i need to be with met
and then when i got done one of the guys
in my program said robert i'm in a men's
program you know we meet two or three
times a year for retreats we meet online
it's really great and he told me who the
coach was and who he trained with and i
love the guy that he trained with i said
i'm in and so i joined three years ago
i'm about to start my fourth year every
year there's about 35 to 45 of us we
have retreats and wow it's just blessed
my life and it's improved my marriage
and it's made me more grounded my my
wife has has either met or gotten to
know a number of the men that i know
some have been to my home you know if
i'm on zoom talking to them i'll say
come on come here say hi to you know
this particular friend um and so
me even in my 60s still trying to bumble
my way through through marriage and
relationship i just know if i don't go
spend time with men if i don't have the
support of men if i can't be revealing
myself to men
i'm going to go downhill and my marriage
is going to go downhill with it so yes i
agree with you we need good same-sex
friends and we need to take the focus
off of our partner that he or she should
always be there to meet all of our needs
they can't
[Music]